Just as the sun will come out tomorrow, so
too can we count on those magnificent beefcake
boys and gearhead girls in the Fast and the
Furious franchise to arrive with another action-packed
installment.
From a focus on family to celebrity cameos,
here are the things that happen in every single
Fast and Furious movie.
While Fast Five and Fast & Furious 6 cemented
"family" as a highly memeable character motivation
for Vin Diesel's Dominic Toretto, "family"
has always been the third most important f-word
of the franchise, right behind "fast" and
"furious."
After all, the first film is about a loner
cop finding a community in Dom's DVD-player
stealing crew.
And the sequel is about Paul Walker's Brian
trying to mend fences with his childhood best
friend, Roman, in a story that wouldn't play
out any differently if they were actually
related by blood.
Tokyo Drift is about carving out a place for
yourself apart from a familial legacy you
might not have wanted, and the fourth film
is about what happens when a member of your
family is murdered — you go on a street-racing
rampage.
In short, long before Dom looked right at
the camera and told audiences around the world
—
"I don't have friends, I got family."
— Fast and the Furious has always been about
the family connections we make for ourselves.
The Fast and the Furious franchise as it stands
today feels more like a James Bond spin-off
series than the adventures of a bunch of street-racing
dirtbags that we started with.
Still, even as the stakes have gotten higher
and Dom's family has gotten bigger, a major
constant in the franchise is that most problems
can be solved with fast cars.
It might seem silly to point this out — after
all, one of the two major adjectives in the
franchise's title is related to speed — but
considering how massive the set pieces have
become, it's comforting that the main solution
to any problem has always been fast cars driving
where you wouldn't expect cars to drive.
Whether it's destroying the entire police
force of Rio de Janeiro in Fast Five or taking
out a nuclear submarine in Russia with the
use of an American muscle car, there's no
problem in the Fast and the Furious world
that can't be solved by living your life one
quarter-mile at a time.
"Start out stealing DVD players and ends up
heisting 100 million dollars from Rio."
"Not bad, huh?"
Considering the utility of a properly engineered
vehicle in the Fast and the Furious franchise,
it's no surprise that the crew takes some
time to appreciate their fleet of their vehicles
whenever they can.
The Fast Family are a bunch of gearheads at
heart, and that means their cars aren't just
tools for super-spy adventures — the cars
are a reflection of themselves.
Before the franchise became as action-driven
as it is today, the cars were arguably the
biggest draw of the early films, and that
aesthetic appreciation remains a core driver
in the franchise.
No matter how high the stakes are, there's
always time for the characters to pause and
admire the cars they'll be driving in upcoming
scenes.
That moment arguably reaches its peak in Fate
of the Furious when Little Nobody takes the
Fast Family into a secret government warehouse
full of confiscated vehicles they can use
to rescue Dom.
Just because the world is at stake doesn't
mean we can't take some time to peek under
the hood
Here's something you might not have noticed:
No good guy in the Fast and the Furious franchise
has ever lost a fight.
If that feels surprising, think about some
of the greatest smackdowns in the films.
There's Dom fighting Hobbs in a garage during
Fast Five, Hobbs fighting Shaw early in Furious
7, or Dom fighting literally every other member
of his family in Fate of the Furious.
But these impressive battles don't just belong
to the beefcakes.
Brian somehow manages to beat Kiet in Furious
7, despite the fact the bad guy is played
by real-life Thai martial artist Tony Jaa.
Most fights in the Fast and the Furious universe
either end with the good guy walking away
the clear victor, or the fight itself being
interrupted by circumstances outside of the
hero's control.
With regards to that Hobbs and Shaw smackdown,
the fight only ends when Hobbs is knocked
out of a window by an explosion while covering
for Elena.
When it comes to the Hobbs and Dom slugfest,
it gets interrupted before an unquestionable
victor can be crowned.
As a result, there are rumors of a "can't
lose" contract for some of the actors.
But whether or not that's true, the fact remains
that if you're a good guy in the world of
Fast and the Furious, no weapon raised against
you will prosper.
Even comic relief Roman gets a moment in Fate
of the Furious where he knocks a guy off a
snowmobile with a car door before shooting
three other faceless goons.
The Fast and the Furious franchise has earned
a bit of a reputation for being needlessly
complex, which isn't really fair.
After all, the order of the films are simple.
If you want to watch it chronologically, you
just watch The Fast and the Furious, the short
film Turbo Charged Prelude to 2 Fast 2 Furious,
2 Fast 2 Furious, the short film Los Bandoleros,
Fast & Furious, Fast Five, Fast & Furious
6 until the post-credits scene, then watch
half of Fast & Furious: Tokyo Drift.
After that, take a break, for sure, then watch
the post-credits to Fast & Furious 6, watch
most of the rest of Fast & Furious: Tokyo
Drift, watch Furious 7 until Dom wants to
go to Tokyo, then finish watching the very
end of Fast & Furious: Tokyo Drift before
completing Furious 7 and enjoying Fate of
the Furious.
Oh, and watch Better Luck Tomorrow if you're
a completionist and want to see the origin
of Han.
Simple, right?
Okay, maybe the franchise has gotten pretty
complex, but that's what happens when you
keep building on the continuity without writing
characters off between films.
Each installment showcases either the appearance
of an old character or at least a tossed-off
mention to previous films.
It can take the form of Brian investigating
Fast & Furious villain Braga midway through
Fast & Furious 6, or Dom relying on his Fast
Five crew in Fate of the Furious.
But no matter who shows up or when, you can
always count on some familiar faces to pop
up in a Fast and the Furious film.
With each new Fast and the Furious film's
budget ballooning into the hundreds of millions,
it's no stretch to say the movies are known
for their jaw-dropping action.
But even when the budget was in the sub-hundred
million range, the filmmakers still found
a way to pack plenty of action into the films.
The Fast and the Furious features a climax
in which one of Dom's men is wired tight to
a semi-truck while the driver shoots a shotgun
at Dom's crew.
Meanwhile, 2 Fast 2 Furious ends with Roman
and Brian launching a car onto a boat like
someone trying to weaponize the Dukes of Hazzard
boys.
And Tokyo Drift finds Han and the ostensible
protagonist, Sean Boswell, drifting through
the Tokyo streets as crowds of people part
like the Red Sea.
By the time Fast Five rolls around, the films
have gotten so big that Brian and Dom are
destroying Rio with a vault that they're using
like a wrecking ball.
There's no telling what insane set pieces
we can expect in the future, but if there's
anything that lives up to Dom leaping across
a bridge from his car to save Letty from getting
knocked off a tank, we can all die happy.
At its core, the first Fast and the Furious
film is a movie with simple pleasures in mind.
There are cars, and they will go fast.
There are tough guys, and they will win fights.
There are beautiful girls in bikinis that
are big fans of both cars and tough guys,
and they will dance.
Even as the films have rounded out the cast,
those core ideals remain the same.
No matter what destinations the Fast Family
visit, there's always going to be time for
a race, and there are always going to be beautiful
women that are excited to watch.
Even while Dom was working to restore Letty's
memory in Fast & Furious 6, there was a London
street race that featured plenty of car girls.
It might be one of the strongest connective
tissues uniting the various locales in the
franchise, a signifier of car culture that
surpasses any sort of division or geographical
line.
Or, most likely, it's because the Fast and
the Furious directors like shooting scenes
with gorgeous women in exotic locales.
It's not all seriousness and widescreen action
when you're a part of Dom's crew.
Sure, there's a chance that you'll be blown
up by a former SAS operative or that you'll
fall onto an endless airplane runway in the
middle of a gun battle, but there are good
times, too.
After all, Dom knows how to throw a killer
party, even if the beer selection is limited.
"You can have any brew you want.
As long as it's a corona."
Every film in the Fast and the Furious franchise
has made time for a party, whether it's the
now traditional post-action barbecue or the
low-budget house party of The Fast and the
Furious.
Even Furious 7, grim as everything was in
the wake of Han's untimely murder, still found
time to have a party DJ-ed by T-Pain in Abu
Dhabi.
When you live your life one quarter-mile at
a time, you've got to leave room to celebrate.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Fast
Saga are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.